ray good morning how are you I'm good
what's up with you dad well I was
curious about your game because I saw
where I think you were playing with
Aaron Rodgers yesterday is that correct
yeah we played we played the last two
days all right any trash-talking between
you two
no you know air is very very low-key
like he's a trash talker one when he's
winning so I got to make sure that I
keep pouring it on the bus
we we we've had some pretty good matches
over the years so we like to keep going
we always have a running tally
throughout the weekend - what a
tournament starts now you see how his
size how do you think you would fare in
the NFL if you look at Aaron Rodgers I
don't know what you're taller than him
he probably weighs more than you how do
you think you would fare with those hits
in the NFL
well even now my playing weight I'm
about 10 to 12 pounds under my playing
weight in the NBA so I'm very slim my
body doesn't require you know all the
food that I put into it and the constant
listen to every single day so you take
that weight that I had which is about
I'm about to to 208 209 going into a
game to play football for me I would
probably have to be 220 225 you know you
know that that would mean a lot more
lifting and definitely a lot more eating
so right now in my weight I get broken
up in as well but you've faced a lot of
big guys including Shaq so the most
physical guy in like didn't did you take
a charge against somebody you never
should have taken a charge yes yes and I
still remember very vividly - it was
actually it was it was a bad idea this
was this was my rookie year and I just
remembered you know just trying to be on
the good side of the coach you know I
was never really a charge taker and I
just seen this guy big guy you know come
down Lane and he had hands like his the
size of one of his hands inside but both
the sides of my boat both hands and he
palmed the ball came down the lane
it was oldest story yeah and I caught
myself get in the middle of it he just
went up
and it just was like he put his knee
into my chest and that was like that was
like that moment when you learn our own
New Yorker of what you're not going to
do ever again yeah but I remember the
worst one when Mark Jackson was trying
to take a charge on Tom Chambers and
chambers yeah like that was one of the
nastiest dunks in traffic of all time
yeah and you know today as a kid you
know dad that's one of the dogs that I
seen Tom Chambers become months ago when
I seen him immediately that's the first
thing I thought of
he's you know he's he's probably just
one of the top ten
dunks of all time and most people don't
remember that it was Mark Jackson so you
know the little guys you know you you
have to do you mess with those big guys
big guys can jump you know you stand
around around like it's not the
territories you to be in so you gotta
make sure that you know who can jump and
it was a dunker because otherwise now
Dan is so much tougher because the if
you get dunked on now we always say
social media is undefeated like you'll
be you'll be a meme so fast you don't
want to be don't go unless a lot
I'm curious couple of basketball
questions here that now we're viewing
Golden State it's not fair that they're
bad for basketball
what is your take as a former player
looking at what Golden State has done
and just did in the offseason with
boogie cousins well I mean listen you
know the salary cap is what it is
players will move however they choose to
move but you know with you the one thing
we've always said I've always said as a
player like anybody who who gets a
salary who can afford to get paid you
know we shake his hand and congratulate
him because it certainly opens up the
door for the future generation of
players coming to leagues so now it's up
to the rest of the league to somewhat
adjust to it you know that's kind of how
it is the the game adapt you know it
kind of natural selection so everybody
else we have to adjust to it know the
players have a choice to be able to go
they won't they become free agents
you know everybody makes different
choices and for me you know I was in a
similar situation you know you decide to
go where you want and that's your choice
so you know what they're what they're
capable of doing hey we
they won three in the last four years so
you know now it's up to a team to step
up and then kind of this matter who they
are but we also I know that Durant got
criticism for leaving Oklahoma City to
go to Golden State you got criticism for
going from Boston to Miami how is there
an easy way to do I don't LeBron's not
getting criticized by going to the
Lakers but he's not going to a you know
team that's gonna be playing for a title
here in the next year or two
is it fair that you and Durant got
criticized for leaving teams to go to a
team that you know would be considered
one of the favorites if not the favorite
well the interesting thing is you know
most people who criticize me they always
said that if if I went to Phoenix they
were doing okay with it so my choice is
make them feel better as long as I don't
go somewhere where they don't like or
where they don't feel bad about where I
also p.m. where I have an opportunity to
win the whole objective for us as
individuals as free agents as athletes
as businessmen is to go somewhere where
potentially maybe you can make more
money or you have a chance to win so I
just don't understand the dilemma or the
the confusion you know every player in
professional sports is trying to win and
when you have that opportunity that's
what you're supposed to do you know
we've been on bad teams most of us and
when you have that opportunity you make
the decision to go somewhere you win and
and then today you can criticize before
but I guarantee you every person that
criticizes them when faced with the
situations that they're they're put in
play 82 games and win 30 35 40 percent
of your games 45 percent 50 if you're on
a good team to know you could win more
that's ultimately what we're we're here
to do is to win games and I'm I don't
criticize anybody who wants to win I
have a theory about the Lakers and I
want to know what you think
I think the Lakers should design a team
that is the exact opposite of the
Warriors because nobody nobody can play
the Warriors style better than the
Warriors so why are we trying to build
rosters that are similar in style to the
Warriors so if I get physical
I get defensive guys ia you know they
like that's where I'm gonna start
I may not beat the Warriors but I know
I'm not gonna beat them at their own
game
I'm gonna beat them up what do you think
well the interesting part is that's not
necessarily a bad idea what you think
about how the Eastern Conference plays
and how the Western science plays you
know for most of my years I don't know
numbers wise but I always felt like I
scored easier when I was 10 against
Western Conference teams or certainly
when I played in Seattle so when you had
an opportunity you know there's it's a
much more open system so the way go to
the state plays they have a freer way of
playing and that's kind of transformed
into the rest of the NBA because you
know that's what's used just to your
point they're trying to figure out ways
to beat this team so they're trying to
join them in the way they play but you
know one thing that we always did
whenever we went out west any team I
played on was we tried to clog the paint
and we tried to double-team the ball and
make their big playmakers get rid of the
ball to make somebody else beat you
mm-hmm
what I see a lot of how you know Golden
State plays is they they never
contribute to to the ball you know with
Steph has the ball with clay has ball
both guys are great and pickle rolls
with Kevin Durant has the ball you know
tremendous score and the argument will
be made well he's just gonna pass
somebody else well I'm scouting each
individual player and reading their
place the person who you know the three
beats you you know a tour all day long
but I'm getting them off the three-point
line I'd rather than have to take tough
twos so you're right defensively if you
build a team that can counter everything
that they do I think you stand a better
chance long-term and then you have guys
that know how to move the ball and still
can shoot a little bit you want to be
the greatest shooters in the world but
just defensively is if you keep them
from from winning because now we're in
the segment in the NBA where office is
when the chairmanship not defense you at
your best
versus Steph Curry at his best
who's a better shooter
you know I then I always compare myself
you know how I played more to klay
Thompson just watching Steph he's
somewhat in a world of his own because
the way he you got great handles and he
had the ball you know 80 percent of the
time so but just a shooting contest just
shooting contest it's you clay Steph you
pick your spot who's the better shooter
out of you three um again I think it'll
be a hell of a shooting contest but what
I would do is I would put them on the
move
you know you know the one thing that I
always tried to mmm the hone in on is
kind of moving because they're both nice
dancer shooters but moving backwards
moving left to right front to back in
threes and both of the do that do that
well but that is really where you see
shooting at its finest because the
three-point contest is fun and it's
interesting but imagine if you adapted a
contest where you just didn't stand
there and shoot the ball you have to
start in one position to get to the next
spot and then shoot and then make that
shot like that would be a much more
interesting contest
I like that I'll leave you with this but
the defender you would like to see one
more time and the defender that you
never want to see again would be who I
mean the easiest for me as Roos born I
don't ever want to see him again like
Bruce Rahl was like you know he he was
and and you know probably over the
sidelines he would be a pause I was like
you know you're okay and I was like go
get him go get him and I frustrate him
like are you okay he was yeah it was
designated you know no matter what was
happening on the floor he was designated
strictly for guarding me he wouldn't
look at the rebound the ball went up he
just always made sure that he sat in my
lap so he's definitely somebody I don't
want to see again okay who's the
defender that you would love to just
have one more game against come on be
honest ray you're done
I don't I don't know I mean I honestly
then there were not too many people that
I felt you know to get in front of me
and I like to tire people out I like to
move up and down and a lot of guys they
had to be committed and you know
starting on the game
I could tell certain guys if they were
gonna commit to running all that day
long even if I knew I wasn't gonna get
the ball come on right give me one guy
you just you couldn't wait to get to
that city because you knew he was he was
gonna be guarding you I don't mean I got
to think about that so you that's it
that's it I'm a golf course thinking
about that and I hope I don't hit the
ball like if Steve Nash was guarding
yeah I mean come on right
you could torch Steve Nash well I mean I
I you know what I guess not just Steve
Nash because Steven Garvey but I would
say more Raja Bell you know cuz that's a
great question because even when we
played the Sun yeah I swear I lost six
pounds that game because they ran so
much and so it was fun to go up and down
because the ball was going in there we
shoot threes we were taking the first
shot available so I would say that's
that's a fair shot I would say you know
when Roger velka's he was a tough
defender no matter how many shots I made
he came right back at me every single
time so he was serving somebody I look
forward to playing it could if I
blindfolded you from the free-throw line
how many how many do you think you could
make out of a hundred out of a hundred
yeah yeah I mean do I get to stop and
take a break alright I'm gonna do what I
want to know what your percentage would
be if you shot a total of a hundred
free-throws blindfolded and I did it in
20 you know increments of 20 in
increments of 20 I would say at out of
10 let's start our 10 I make so you're
blindfolded ray and you shoot better
than guys who can actually see yeah
because you know there's one thing about
basketball around
learn this is that the court doesn't
change you know there's no element you
know when rain you know I shoot that
free-throw line every single day after
every drill every routine and really
whenever I'm in a slump or you know I
can't get my time where those are three
per line so a lot of times you know how
the ball needs to leave your fingers you
put your foot on a nail at the
free-throw line so it's just getting
really getting the ball in the air and
sitting in on that RIM soft enough so
even if you know swishing the ball to
have a chance to go in yeah
that's how we the great ones do it right
no this takes a lot of work and tell you
what when you're retired you don't have
to sit back and have nightmares about
every single day I I got say this I
could be watching a college game or an
NBA game
a 94 game and I see one player missed a
free throw and that's going to have me
have a bad night I'm thinking I do not
want that leave me I don't want to be me
but you're not playing anymore that's
why I said in retirement that's the
beautiful thing
don't worry about it
that bad you want to perform but when
you go to the line and it's quiet in the
gym and everybody's watching and it's
would you rather have a dead silent or
people yelling and screaming as you go
to the line with you know with the game
on the line well that's interesting
because you know I'm in the gym all day
long where it's dead quiet you know
before you know 9:00 in the morning in
the morning it's you know before a game
you know I'm always by myself shooting
free throws so when it's game time I go
back to that moment in my head you know
you kind of stay in to yourself you
focus on you know your hand your ball
where your feet need to be you focus on
the rim you know you really clear the
people out of your mind and you just do
what you've been doing and so what you
have to do when you're by yourself is
you have to almost bring those people
into the building with you while you're
shooting so you get familiar in that
situation so it's a weird way of
imposing people in and out of your
existence while you're while you're
competing so you know that's the only
way you could you can do it especially
down the stretch when it comes to being
down too and you have to make two free
throws it's like you
see that guy steps are free tomorrow you
don't have to worry about that anymore
though ray have fun this weekend out
there in Tahoe and we appreciate your
time as always thank you that's Ray
Allen two-time NBA champ 10 time
all-star going into the Basketball Hall
of Fame for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]